nous voici au laboratoire de santé
publique du québec une véritable
fourmilière depuis deux ans si nous lui
avons fait passer le premier le premier
virus au canada faire pousser un virus
ça veut dire qu'on prélève des
échantillons à partir des tests positifs
de kovy 19 et on vérifie entre autres
pendant combien de temps le virus est
capable de se multiplier dans les
cellules les résultats suggèrent que la
contagion cesse après dix jours ces
études menées un peu partout dans le
monde ont influencé la durée d'isolement
des malades venez discuter par exemple
de ces études là c'est qu'ils ont
recruté les aides des populations ont
des participants relativement jeune donc
l'âge moyen dans ses études au seuil
entre 35 et 50 ans le microbiologiste
infectiologue docteur yves longtemps
s'inquiétaient du fait que les personnes
âgées sont pourtant contagieuse plus
longtemps que dix jours quand elles
contractent l'influenza étant donné la
faiblesse de leur système immunitaire
pour vérifier si c'est aussi le cas pour
la co vide l'hôpital général juif de
montréal a recruté 22 patients de 80 ans
et plus dans les ch et celle des afin
d'étudier en laboratoire si le virus est
toujours présent aujourd'hui on était
très surpris quand on est rendu dans
l'orne du 12 sur 22 encore contagieux
mais à ce moment alors on se rend compte
que clairement il se passe possiblement
un signal qui se passe quelque chose
contagieux après des jours même si
pratiquement tous leurs symptômes
avaient disparu et on va savoir le
danger potentiel que peut causer une
personne âgée qui est malade pendant
plus de dix jours donc on sait
maintenant sur papier de 50% ces gens ne
sont encore l'infection cette découverte
une première canadienne pourrait avoir
des impacts sur les décideurs non
seulement sur la durée d'isolement des
aînés mais aussi sur l'équipement de
protection personnelle des travailleurs
de la santé qui les soignent le docteur
longtin et son équipe lancent un appel
international aux scientifiques pour
qu'il poursuivre cette recherche auprès
d'un échantillon plus grands est ce que
maintenant est ce qui demeure contagieux
12 jours quinze jours 20 jours une
attitude ne peux pas répondre à cette
question là il va falloir faire une
autre étude on va devant suivre les
patients de façon longitudinale et les
tester plusieurs moments pour pouvoir
déterminer le moment où ils ne sont plus
contagieux cette étude démontre qu'on a
probablement sous-estimé la contagiosité
des aînés durant la pandémie et elle
pourrait même fournir certaines réponses
aux enquêtes visant à expliquer
l'hécatombe dans les chu celle des
durant la première vague ici véronique
prince radio canada québec